let's go next to Jason from Mount Juliet
Jason from Mount Juliet welcome to the
program
hey David thanks for having me pleasure
I actually wanted to ask you about the
tweet from earlier this week sure um
that you're getting a little bit of heat
Farm a little bit yeah yeah a little bit
so I honestly think that overall it was
pretty
pretty rough but at the same time you
made a very valid point because there
has to be something done beyond what the
typical response has been right and let
me say just because you're here and by
the way you're in Tennessee
I am you know what I there have been
people who could like Candace Owens
keeps hammering on why won't I apologize
so it's like well listen I'm not going
to apologize for the statement I made
which was thoughts and prayers don't
stop school shootings we need to do more
however what I did learn Jason is that
even though anyone in my audience when
they see the Tweet they go David's not
blaming kids for getting shot he's
blaming the people who don't do anything
other than thoughts and prayers my
audience gets it that sarcasm doesn't
translate well number one to people who
don't already know me and number two to
people who might understand that it's
sarcasm but they want to pretend it's
not in order to attack me rather than
talk about guns so it still was a
learning experience for me the sarcasm
may not work well in tweets
oh for sure I I would also say there's
probably a third uh category there of
people who are typically not terminally
online like a lot of us are so we
understand the humor we understand your
point because of you know just
the discussions we have regularly on the
internet sure but people who just peruse
and can have uh somebody like Donald
Trump Jr uh kind of
Echo a sentiment against what we are
saying or what you said to make it look
bad is
it makes sense that you got the Flack
you did I agree I wanted to say that I
as somebody from Tennessee
um not originally here from here but who
lives here now and who has a little one
who goes to a school very similar to the
one that um
the tragedy happened at yeah I
you made a very valid point and I wish
that my state would do something more
than what we're getting from our
Representatives I'm with you Jason I'm
with you appreciate the call hey man
have a good one all right Jason from
Tennessee let's take just a very quick
break and I'm going to take more calls
so stay stay with us on the Discord if
you'd still like to get on we'll take
the quickest of breaks and be right back